ich liebe Pizza ich habe Pizza beim
Weltmeister gegessen und sie hat mich zu
Tränen gerührt ich war bei Gordon ramsis
Street Pizza habe die getestet und viel
wichtiger ich backe gerne Pizza und habe
jumbo Schreiner zu dieser Aussage bewegt
die Pizza ist für mich eine 10 und ich
würde mit dieser Pizza stolz geschwelt
in jedem italienischen Laden reingehen
und mit dem Hinlegen guckst du diese
Mann macht der Pizza richtig mit anderen
Worten ich glaube ich kann etwas über
Pizza sagen und wenn ich dann höre dass
meine Kollegen trymacs und knossi eine
Pizza Kette aufgemacht haben werde ich
hellhörig happy Slice heißt das ganze
und ich habe mir gedacht einfach eine
Pizza bestellen und zu bewerten wer
irgendwie zu langweilig ich will euch
ein bisschen was besseres bieten deshalb
werde ich heute jede einzelne happy
slides Pizza bestellen und für euch
herauszufinden welche die beste ist ich
hätte glaube ich besser zwei drei Tage
davon nichts essen sollen also macht
euch gefasst auf eine Pizza Party in der
wir herausfinden wie gut happy Slice
wirklich ist das Team von Happy slide
war so nett und hat mir in 25 € Code
geschickt ich glaube wir werden so ein
bisschen über diesen Betrag hinausgehen
deshalb blende ich den euch hier unten
einer kann sich der erste von euch was
davon gönnen wir gehen jetzt in die
liefer-app und bestellen die gesamte
Karte gucken wir erstmal was ich da so
drauf befindet happy Slice Südstadt und
da oben sehen wir schon die beiden Jungs
die ganz stolz ihre Pizza präsentieren
und die Fotos von den Pizzen geben schon
so einen ersten Eindruck gucken wir
einmal über die Karte Sunny Salami mad
Marita wiegen funny funghi holiday
Hawaii wiegen Margarita also es gibt auf
jeden Fall verschiedene Pizzen aber wenn
ich mir schon so das Namensschema
angucken wollen die gar nicht klassische
italienisch sein weil alles ist so im
American so coole interessante
namensspiele hinter den sich eigentlich
Klassiker verstecken bis wir runter
scrollen an den ein oder anderen
ebenfalls Klassikern vorbei javolo torno
funghi Hawaii Mister sehen wir die
veganen Pizzen aber auch zwei special
Pizzen einmal tasty travel und happy
Hollands wir wollen also testen wie gut
sind die Klassiker und wie gut sind die
eigene Kreation deshalb habe ich jetzt
erstmal alles in den Warenkorb wir haben
12 Pizzen und den Cookie im Warenkorb
und der Gesamtpreis sind 158
35 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 Pizzen
sind da es gibt aber eigentlich 14
scheinbar hat diese Ghost kitchen zwei
Pizzen nicht angeboten was wir leider
jetzt erst erfahren haben aber
vielleicht ist das das erste Problem das
mit Ghost kitchens auftreten kann
vielleicht waren auch einfach die Sachen
out of stock wir fangen an mit der
allerersten Pizza das ist eine Pizza
Margherita eine hübsche Pizza mehr darf
man nicht sagen oder sie sehen hier die
Krone das erinnert vielleicht direkt ein
bisschen einen knossi und interessant
ist auch direkt der Teig der uns hier
anspringt denn das ist ein panzerteil
gucken wir mal wie die erste Pizza
schmeckt vorgeschnitten schon mal
wichtig bin ich umgeschnitten ankommen
probieren
ich habe das auch so ziemlich die
schlimmste Bestellung die du als
Pizzaladen bekommen kannst jede Pizza
einmal so dann können nicht so fünf auf
einmal machen sondern jede einzelne ich
mag die Süße der Tomatensoße an einem
beliebigen Orten Deutschland ist das
eine Pizza mit dem man sehr zufrieden
sein kann wenn man sie geliefert bekommt
sofort mehr als konkurrenzfähig würde
ich sagen happy Slice Happy Life für
dich an der Stelle sagen ich bin
übrigens nicht bezahlt oder so ich habe
die Rechnung selbst bezahlt Benchmark
Margarita Test bestanden für mich eine
klassische 8,2 das hier ist Pizza keine
Ahnung also ehrlich gesagt wirklich gar
keine Ahnung ich guck mal hier haben wir
also die wiegen matt Margarita Veganer
Käse ist manchmal so ein bisschen cremig
so fast ein bisschen flüssig ich weiß
nicht ob das dieser Mann der Käse ist
der verklebt an so ein bisschen den Mund
hat aber eine schöne Würzigkeit direkt
aber für mich nicht ganz so gut wie die
erste Margarita das ist eine klassische
6,9 das werde ich auf jeden Fall
brauchen und ich sage ehrlich nach den
ersten zwei Stücken es ist so ein
bisschen trockener es gibt nicht so
ultra saftigen napolitanischen voll
belegten Pizzen das fehlt hier ein
bisschen Pizza trutono
Tonno jede Menge Tonno also wurde nicht
geizt am Thunfisch wir sehen auch jetzt
normaler Käse drauf rote Zwiebeln
Tomatensoße Käse Rezept hier haben wir
wiegen funny funghi das heißt
wahrscheinlich der Käse wieder der
gleiche aber es wird eine interessante
neue Geschmackskomposition denn wir
haben ja die anderen Komponenten dabei
man muss jetzt schon sagen die Pizzen
verändern sich jetzt nicht in der kurzen
Zeit in der wir schon testen immer noch
knusprig immer noch schön gleich
verbeugen sich immer noch der Unterboden
ist übrigens auch echt schön geworden
muss ich an der Stelle mal sagen und
dieser pinselteig ist sowieso geil auf
der Website steht glaube sogar dass er
aus Italien kommt hatte eben diese
Reifezeit und so weiter und so fort und
wird dadurch wirklich zu einem guten
Pizzateig
schmeckt mir auf jeden Fall besser als
ohne die Pilze 7,2 von mir ich finde man
merkt jetzt schon dass diese Pizza ganz
anders gebacken wurde als sie davor sie
ist ein bisschen weicher bzw
wahrscheinlich hat der Belag einfach im
Ofen auch mehr Feuchtigkeit abgegeben so
dass sie halt vielleicht einfach eine
andere dann ist halt also sie liegt
jetzt halt schon ordentlich ab aber
entscheidend bleibt immer der Geschmack
probieren wir
fast der Stick so viel Belag war darauf
jetzt gerade verstehe ich hier was aber
es ist einfach eine geile und
standard-pizza diese Pizzen kennt jeder
von uns wir haben auch noch zwei special
Pizzen die wir unbedingt testen müssen
später tasty travel und happy Holland
gleichbelegt lecker knusprig ist schon
gut Alter ist schon echt verdammt gut
geht erstmal eine Note 7 halb die große
Frage ist aber wir haben die das
geschafft ich dachte mir auch erstmal
was mache ich eigentlich falsch dass ich
Kochvideos mache und die Jungs haben
einfach über Nacht 70 Restaurants bei
200 Restaurants in Deutschland eröffnet
die Antwort auf die Frage lautet Ghost
kitchen das heißt mit anderen Worten
Jungs bzw die Firma HAPPY Slice schickt
Produkte an bestehende Restaurants das
heißt das kann deine Pizzeria von
nebenan sein die zentral den Teig die
Zutaten alles geliefert bekommt mit den
Zutaten bereiten die Ghost kitchens dann
strengen nach Rezept genau das Produkt
zu dass es sein soll in der Theorie
deshalb kannst du durchaus sein dass das
nicht einfach rote Zwiebeln sind weil
ich meine es gibt auch verschiedene rote
Zwiebeln und dann kauft ein Restaurant
vielleicht die falschen ein sondern es
könnte wirklich sein dass sie vielleicht
eingelegt kommen um Halt zu diesem
gewissen Geschmack diese Charakteristik
in jedem Restaurant in jedem Laden bei
jeder Bestellung gewährleisten zu können
das aber auch nichts ganz neues ich habe
vor einiger Zeit mal Beast Burger von MR
Beast getestet der nutzt genau das
gleiche Prinzip und es ist schon
ziemlich genial muss ich sagen weil ich
meine die Jungs haben überall in
Deutschland oder überall im
deutschsprachigen Raum Zuschauer und so
kann halt jeder in den Genuss von Ihrem
Produkt kommen tasty travel einer der
beiden special Pizzen insgesamt bewegen
die sich zwischen 10 und 15 € was schon
bisschen höherpreisiger ist ich finde es
wirklich schwer irgendwen für seine
Preisgestaltung zu kritisieren weil wir
leben halt einfach Inflation
die nicht vegane Version von der Funke
die wir gerade schon hat immer noch
schön warm immer noch knusprig
der vegane Käse war ein bisschen
salziger der gefällt mir von der Textur
besser
7,2 die Pizza müsste ein bisschen
salziger sein sieht sie nach 15 Euro aus
ist auf jeden Fall eine weiße Pizza
keine Tomatensoße ganz genau Pizza
Bianca das freut mich aber auch weil
jetzt gerade schon viel von der
Tomatensoße probiert wir sind
12345 Pizzen drin das ist Nummer 6
Halbzeit ich freue mich dass Sie eine
Pizzeria ist wir haben diese kleinen
Padano der Käse wird dann auch beim
Namen genannt Champignons trüffelcreme
gucken wir ob sie ihr Geld wert ist wow
also wirklich an der Stelle das
lieferkonzept dass ich was gedacht haben
bei dem Mehl Blend drei verschiedene
Mehlsorten damit sie länger knusprig
bleibt das stimmt bin gespannt wie sehr
die nach Trüffel schmeckt wie schwer
davon aus dass er kein echter Trüffel
drin ist aber Trüffelgeschmack den man
kennt ist ja häufig synthetisch
also diese Pizza gefällt mir verdammt
gut
geschmacklich unnormal gut unnormal gut
auf der gerade ein paar Dano würde sagen
tasty truffle kriegt 9,5 Punkte das ist
wirklich etwas mit dem ich nicht
gerechnet hätte richtig geile Pizza mein
Gefühl das könnte unser vorläufiger
Gewinner sein aber wir haben ja auch
noch eine weitere special Pizza weiter
geht's boah der Karton ist schwer mit
Happy Hollandaise die sieht wirklich
pervers aus wir sehen Kochschinken wir
sehen Spargel getrocknete Cherrytomaten
ich sage euch ganz ehrlich ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen dass die mich genauso
überrascht wie die tasty das ist so ein
Apparat probiert
weiter geht's Pizza
Magic Mister und die ist zur Hälfte die
die ich mir bestellt hätte denn hier ist
die Schafe Salami drauf ich warte die
ganze Zeit auf Doktor Diabolo von der
gesamten Liste hat die mich am meisten
angesprochen ich bin gespannt ob die
später mit der trüffelpizza mithalten
kann auf der einen Hälfte gekochter
Schinken grüne Paprika auf der anderen
Hälfte Peperoni Wurst und wieder diese
Zwiebeln die führt mir eine Sache vor
Augen und zwar das bei allen bisherigen
Pizzen mir ein bisschen so diese
Saftigkeit gefehlt hat ich finde die
schmeckt aber nicht schlecht und so
diese Saftigkeit macht schon viel gut
ganz ehrlich mein Bauchgefühl sagt mir
das ist eine 8,0 hätte nicht gedacht
dass ich das darüber sagen würde für wen
ist diese Pizza gemacht für Leute die
sich nicht entscheiden können beim
Prinzip ist das einmal die Doktor
diabola und einmal eine prototo die
Pizza testen wir als letztes weil ich
werde einfach Mittelwert bilden aus der
Doktor Diavola und aus der prototo
endlich ist sie da dr diabola die Pizza
die ich mir auf Anhieb bestellt hätte
die sieht irgendwie auch am besten aus
oder die füllen zu perfekt den Karton
aus schöner Rand
weiter geht's mit Sunny Salami nicht zu
verwechseln mit Sami Slimani verloren
aber ich zeige euch einseitig noch
trotzdem geben wir jeder Pizza die Fähre
Chance und stellen unsere
Geschmacksknospen wieder von vorne an
weil die trifft alle Punkte die eine
Salami Pizza Treffen soll finde ich boah
Leute ist das eigentlich ein Cheat day
heute ich glaube schon besser als ich
gedacht hätte Salami mag ich eigentlich
gar nicht deshalb 8,0 endlich bist du da
ich probiere
die Trauben sich deutlich mehr als ich
gedacht hätte echt meine Zunge brennt
richtig ein bisschen Tränen in die Augen
ja also nicht weil die nicht so rührt
wie die von Francesco sondern weil die
wirklich verdammt scharf ist und alleine
deshalb macht die mir jetzt schon so
viel mehr Spaß als diese Salami Pizza
ich merk was also ich habe einen
zusätzliches Gefühl gerade dabei und ich
mag das Gefühl dr diabola 9,0 damit ist
sie nicht auf Platz 1 weiter geht's mit
Hawaii und sie heißt wirklich einfach
nur Hawaii alle heißen irgendwie tasty
triffel happy Hollande Sony warum hast
ich schlage vor dass wir sie heavy
Hawaii nennen doch drei 14 übrig das
hier ist perfekt prototo und ich bin
gespannt wie perfekt sie ist der sieht
so bisschen so so trocken aus irgendwie
der Schinken nee einfach nur den
Schinken genauso wie aussieht
dadurch dass man nur mit einem bisschen
den Prosciutto hat ist das im Prinzip
für mich eine Margarita die durch den
Schinken aber ein bisschen abgewertet
wird hatte 8,2 das ist eine 7,9 es tut
mir Leid der Schinken war es nicht für
mich und direkt zum Schluss die
kontroverseste Pizza der Albtraum eines
jeden Italieners und auch mein
persönlicher Albtraum denn ich habe viel
zu viel Pizza gegessen wir haben das
gleiche wie bei der prototo bisschen
gestreut ein zwei fleißig in der Mitte
aber wir haben die Ananas beides
ist nicht so happy aus
bittere Note von der Ananas kam wenn man
halt Pizza Hawaii Markt wird man die
schon mögen mir ist gerade noch mal
aufgefallen ich mag Pizza Hawaii nicht
so gerne Hawaii kriegt von mir 7,0 Magic
Mister die letzte die wir noch haben ist
ja eine Hälfte Diabolo eine Hälfte Proto
der Mittelwert sind 8,5 2 Stücke könnte
ich jetzt nicht mehr essen heute bin ich
ganz ehrlich mit euch aber es bleibt ein
wirklich positiver Eindruck von Happy
Slice ich hätte nicht gedacht dass es so
solide ist weil solide es finde ich
wirklich eine gute Bezeichnung für die
meisten der Pizzen ungehauen hat mich
die tasty Traffic hätte ich niemals
gedacht dass es mir so gut gefallen
würde mein persönlicher Gewinner und
damit ist auch die Frage vom Anfang
geklärt ich empfehle euch tasty es hat
eine Menge Spaß gemacht ich habe das
Gefühl ich bin jetzt pizzaexperte so wie
ich mich darauf eingeschossen habe ich
hoffe das Video hat Euch gefallen falls
ihr schon mal happy slide bestellt habt
was ist eure lieblings Pizza wir sehen
uns beim nächsten Video wieder bis dahin
macht's gut und ciao